project management techniques project
management techniques you really had a
few different valid answers here ok so I
was actually quite broad if you just
said one and you didn't you've left out
a few bits and I didn't I didn't
penalize you but there were bits of
pilot and phased implementation both
visible in the system ok they pile in it
with a small area and then they sort of
on a bigger scale they're phasing you
near there introducing is slowly okay
and that makes sense because it's not
like you can have all those card readers
just magically instantly installed
everywhere else right it takes time to
install those right so that's why with
any large system phased implementation
happens quite frequently ok now let's
see here physical money transactions are
still accepted right so some of you
might have said ok that's kind of like a
parallel conversion and I said ok that's
fine because it is right you've got the
pay the money system cash system and
you've got the herbal system and they're
both running together it's not like
you've only got part of one and part of
the other ok you can only pay money here
and family there so if you said parallel
even that was ok so so long as you
didn't say direct you could have said
any conversion method and you already
gotten something ok so you're welcome
now apart from that what other kinds of
project management techniques was I
looking for things like you can talk
about the feasibility when you read the
article you can see they studied
technical operational economic schedule
feasibility so you could have said a
feasibility site that when I'm fine
question Go Go other people need to go
for lunch time stuff Christina did you
have a question you're going to you just
scrape that's fine okay no ice that's
fine um ok so by the way for technical
operational economic and schedule
feasibility if you mentioned those this
is an important note for you later on
because I didn't really have a specific
question about it but you will in the
trial you can't just say they studied
technical feasibility or they invest in
an operational feasibly you've got to
say well what about it so let me give
you some examples i'm not sure if
they've already been written here ok
an example of technical feasibility is
well these carriers right we've got to
be able to get them they've got to be in
if they've got to be usable are they are
they cheap that kind of thing is going
to come into economics right but today
does the technology exists right 20
years ago it did not so that's a
technical feasibility issue right people
people will go they rag on the part of
transport because they like you've taken
so long so we're all at this system for
well the technology had to catch up
great design is it so are you going the
operational feasibility that's about
okay look people don't have to line up
so long right a lot of people mentioned
that but they didn't connect it to the
right kind of feasibility right so if
you know that connected to demonstrate
the understand what kind of visibility
they'll study right the economic one
that was an easy one the schedule one
knows little more subtle right you can
see when you were reading the article
they'll talk about our this is how long
it will take to do this and we estimate
this is a long time to do that so that
shows they've been thinking about the
timeline and how long it's going to take
to trial this and then install and so